this video spoils the entire backstory
of Daris nay the new psvr title by from
software if you prefer to experience the
game as if you were playing through
yourself then you might prefer to watch
this video which will present the story
from a player's perspective instead
thanks for watching the law of de Rosnay
is largely inspired by the writings of
Scottish poet Fiona McLeod who wrote
quite often about fairies and the fair
folk and in Western cultures we have a
sort of perception of fairies as being
very childlike and innocent and honestly
the word fairy is a very childish one
but in Fiona's writing they're also
terrible and proud creatures here's one
of his poems how beautiful they are the
lordly ones who dwell in the hills in
the hollow hills they play with Lance's
and a proud and terrible marching in the
moonlight with fierce blue eyes they
love and are loved there is no sin there
but slaying without death and loving
without shame they laugh and are glad
and are terrible when their Lance's
shake and shiver every green reed
Quivers and fairy kind in de Rosnay
live up to these descriptions they love
their terrible they even wield short
Lance's and with those lances they slay
without death
[Music]
so in de Rosnay long ago existed a
fabled academic city called Rome it was
home to many a great fairy tale and many
of its scholars were absolutely devoted
to the truth behind these tales in fact
many of the books that you'll read in
Deborah's name must have come from Rome
and as you explore the world of de
Rosnay you learn what about very kind
and the rules that govern their world
here's three of them first fairies can
transfer life span from one living thing
to another as long as those two beings
are somewhat similar to each other at
the life of one plant to another or the
life of a tiny creature to one close in
size for example larger creatures though
can only share themselves with others of
their ilk a second rule is that if fairy
is in possession of a golden wand the
net power is amplified with a golden
wand a fairy can claim a human's
remaining time and since humans are
obsessed with the distant past fairies
can actually use a human's time to
travel back in time and alter events to
their will and a third rule that governs
fairies is that life and time are
beholden to the two rings that a fairy
wears a red ring of life on their right
hand and a blue ring of time on their
left
and without these rings a fairy is
actually unable to traverse time and
according to this book if a fairy
doesn't find its ring then it will drift
off unceremoniously into the darkness
where the snows of time fall so with
these discoveries five Ronin scholars
set out on a sort of holy crusade to
become fairies and to fix the mistakes
of the past we see a photograph of five
Aronian scholars here three men
and I believe one of them is likely
named Nicholas the one who wrote a
nearby book on ferry utility it reads
the moment we become ferries with our
golden ones the world becomes a place of
endless possibility mistakes of the past
will be undone and the future will only
hold what is right what on earth are we
waiting for
Moroni and colleagues I say again what
on earth are we waiting for
in addition to item descriptions you can
actually read the words on the physical
item itself and this book reads herein I
read five reasons to raise the golden
wand and open the door to infinite
horizons to those who possess the will
to correct history's mistakes read on
justice is that which is born of resolve
however from what we can tell
shortly after their studies on fairies
something went terribly wrong in Rome
residents began to disappear leaving
only their clothing behind and the city
was eventually burned down and forgotten
fairies were behind it of course and
stories of vanishings even began to
appear in nearby areas it wasn't just
limited to the city of Rome and this man
is also one of the last remaining
scholars of Rome and he's likely another
man in the photograph since then many
years have passed since the burning of
Rome and this guy shelters alone in
Rob's forest he clutched as a cat close
to himself as fairies fear cats and he's
being stalked by a fairy who hungers for
his remaining life force the cat hisses
there's a fairy that lingers yet the
insatiable fiend when is it going to
leave I'm sure it would depart if fed
enough time but who would be willing to
make such a sacrifice why would it visit
this site of vanishings unless there is
little trace of our stock across this
whole land these woods are no different
there is no man but I and no beast but
my cat take your fill of time and do
your filthy deeds elsewhere pox on this
mad specter of Rome so one of those
terrifying truths that you learn about
de Rosnay
is that in this world's they may
actually be very few humans left
in the land and it's all because of
these evil fairies who steal the
remaining time from the humans around
them according to this old man's diary
as terrifying as it is to fathom this
may only be a glimpse into the larger
picture and the vanishings may be
spreading and you would think that okay
we kind of created fairies they're going
around and killing everyone for their
time and nothing in the world is getting
better so after all of that you would
think that the academics of Rome might
be dissuaded by all of their mistakes
but instead they double down on them for
two of the other scholars in the
photograph survived to continue their
research and one of them is called the
headmaster and the other is named
margarita eventually you'll find
margaritas diary which reads five
orphans arrived today of course this was
in the name of our research but I refuse
to repeat the mistakes perpetrated in
Rome they shall live in our school and
we shall become their parents and
teachers I dearly hope we'll all be
happy together one day
fairies are drawn towards children and
to harness the power of fairies one only
needs to have a child make a wish in
total margarita and the headmaster had
six six orphans for their experiments
with fairies yes they say that they
wanted to be happy with the children but
really their experiments were still one
of their primary goals but there was a
seventh child a baby named Alexis Alexis
was Margaret as daughter but who her
father is is unclear it's possible that
it's the headmaster as in some
photographs he's actually seen holding a
child but he only ever refers to the
child as margaritas and not his own
regardless the headmaster obsesses over
Margaretta for not long after the death
of Alexis margarita killed herself
drowning herself in the river of Prayer
and the headmaster is partially to blame
no you will be together always deal with
margarita I know I won't ask your
forgiveness after taking what I did from
you this dialogue suggests that the
headmaster is in fact behind what
happened to Margaret his daughter Alexis
and later it's revealed that the plan
with Alexis margaritas baby was to turn
her into a fairy by the grave of Alexis
later in the game we find this
explanation a summary of research
findings on fairies humans who have
become fairies claimed life to travel to
the past it's likely their human
instincts at work a person who is not
obsessed by the distant past may prove
an exception perhaps a newborn baby
would make an ideal candidate the
problem that the roni and scholars ran
into was that fairies began to take huge
quantities of human life for selfish
purposes so when the headmaster and
Margaret have moved to the Academy they
planned to experiment on Margaret his
child to turn her into a fairy for
babies have no pasts to torment them
however soon after the death of Alexis
and before Alexis's rebirth as a fairy
Margaretta killed herself drowning
herself in the river of prayer the
Headmaster's old diary reads Alexis
could not be spared from death but would
have lived on as a fairy but why did you
have to die why drown yourself in the
river clutching the ring have mercy upon
me margarita and tell me where I have
earned it's difficult for us to know why
margarita killed herself as even the
headmaster himself doesn't know the
simplest answer is probably that she was
overcome with grief and guilt and killed
herself after realizing what she had
done to her child but a more likely
answer might be that she had a goal to
her suicide maybe that she wanted to
prevent Alexis becoming a fairy by
stealing the red ring of life and
drowning herself well maybe that she
somehow wished to become
Fairey herself and go back in time and
prevent all of this from happening and
it is possible that margarita was at
least partially successful for Alexis
actually doesn't become a fairy for many
many years after
Margarita's death that is until one of
the orphans a girl named Yulia wishes to
see her again Yulia steals the golden
wand from the headmaster and she writes
him a note reading headmaster I'm going
to borrow the golden wand
I'm very sorry to break my promise but I
just want to see Alexis again Yulia
offers up her life to see Alexis again
and Alexis appears to grant her wish I'm
almost certain that fairies are drawn to
the promise of a red ring of life for
every little fairy gets a little gift
and this is where we appear and the game
begins for upstairs in the Headmaster's
attic amongst other discarded forgotten
things is a picture of a baby named
Alexis crying and clutching a golden
wand and on her left hand is a birthmark
and if we look at our left hand we
noticed the exact same birthmark
we are Alexis Margaret has lost daughter
reborn as a fairy and drawn to the last
wish of one of the children and now the
game begins that was just the law of the
game and if you want to hear the story
of the children and the experience of
what the actual day rest in a gameplay
was like then you can check out part two
on the story of de Rosnay
[Music]
you